you got a contract with the defense
department to do a lunar lander which is
being disputed by Jeff Bezos how do you
feel about that I think you should put
more of his energy into getting to orbit
than lawsuits you cannot see your way to
the Moon okay do you know what how good
your lawyers are so why isn't he doing
that I don't know I also like to make
fun of his rocket we all make fun of
each other's Rockets I mean it could be
a different shape potentially
you know
could you explain from a technological
point of view why it's that shape well
um if you are only going to doing
suborbital then your rocket can be sort
of shorter yes
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggle to believe in myself
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and let's learn what successful
entrepreneurs think about Jeff Bezos
enjoy
Berkshire is not going to out Bezos Jeff
Bezos for sure what did you mean by that
what were you talking about well I mean
that there's certain people that you you
do not want to try and beat at their own
game and certainly Jeff Bezos would be
number one I mean that'd be like me
playing chess with Bobby Fisher you know
40 years ago to be home all over on the
first move uh
Jeff no he's just show an amazing talent
in figuring out how to please customers
and uh and in a very short time and
what's interesting to some extent about
him the same thing is interesting about
Fred Smith of Federal Express
it isn't that they've had some
breakthrough and you know found some
molecule this or that or or
come up with some you know incredible
invention they've taken fairly ordinary
things I mean starting buying books in
them you know but Fred Smith took the
airplane and the delivery truck and the
postal service but then he just put it
together in a very imaginative way you
know with a central Hub and all that and
and came up with a whole new industry
out of components that were known to
everybody and in in a sense Bezos has
done the same thing now he's building
big distribution centers and employing
the latest technology but
the Kindle came out of there and there's
some products but overwhelmingly he's
taken things that you and I were buying
before and he's figured out a way to
make us happier
buying those products either by fast
delivery or prices or whatever it may be
and that's remarkable when you think
about it I mean a lot of that comes down
to just focusing on what the customer
wants that's all he thinks about is is
he he wants the customer to have a smile
on their face but he laid out his
objectives in his first annual report
and you need to read them I mean his
competitors could read him and he has
changed the world in a big way the
Phoenix Suns obviously a big chunk of
the organization going to be up for sale
one of your former teams any any
interest in that check uh obviously
knowing that you are involved in other
places here in the NBA but any interest
in in buying the team I was interested
but when but when big man JB said he was
interested nobody can compete with big
man JB no you know what that is big no
is that who is who's J big man JB Jeff
Bezos
well I'm I'm telling you now once uh
Jeff Bezos put his name in the Hat all
you other just close your checkbook and
go home no nobody even before Shaquille
O'Neal nobody on this planet can't
compete with big man JB and I'm not
gonna be in there you know trying to go
up against big man JB because you know
what I just ordered you know 50 things
off Amazon today
big man JB got that money coming in
how about a big man JB and a big Shaq
partnership what about that if he wants
me aboard I would you know gladly like
to talk to him but you know as far as
trying to own the whole team but myself
and go up against dick let me tell you
something I'm scared of big man JD Shaq
O'Neal scared of big man JB that's his
new name big man JB I don't know what to
say about Amazon I like Amazon nice
company well they're in the cloud they
make no money Charlie in my world you're
not a real business until you make some
money I mean I have a hard time with
businesses that don't make money at some
point yeah I get it if you don't make
money for two or three years yeah but
Amazon's what 21 years old and not
making money oh yeah but it's been
building up they obviously they have
enough stockholders that think highly of
what they're doing and Bravo to them and
Bravo to them but I don't know when
they'll make money and if I was a share
owner
you know it's an expensive company yeah
I mean marketing accounts What 150
billion almost yeah you know eventually
if you if you're worth 150 billion
eventually somebody thinks you're going
to make 15 billion pre-taxed yes they do
and they make about zero and there's a
big gap between 0 and 15. damn also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Amazon and Jeff Bezos have pursued
what might be described as a very asset
heavy business model they're buying
airplanes they want only entire supply
chain from beginning to end and Alibaba
has effectively an asset like business
it is very much in terms of the retail
piece of this the opposite you don't
want to own the warehouses you don't
want to own the logistics companies
how do you think about that is Jeff
Bezos right or are you right and is
there is there going to be a a meeting
in the middle I hope both are right
and because the world can never have one
model if the world has only one
corrector model there was too boring
right we need to have all kinds of
models and the people who do the model
should be leaving the model and I
believe what I do
right the difference between Amazon and
US Amazon is more like an Empire
everything they should control
themselves buy and sell and our
philosophy is that we want to be your
ecosystem our philosophy is to empower
others
to sell Empower others to sit to service
Empower making sure the other people are
more powerful than us making sure with
our technology our Innovation our
partners our 10 million small business
sellers they can compete with Microsoft
IBM our philosophy is that we we think
using internet technology we can make
every company become Amazon does anybody
here think that Bezos wishes he hadn't
bought
a newspaper because think about it any
of you guys got in politics and you went
and started to run an estate you
wouldn't be sitting in your chair
anymore because the media doesn't touch
a guy that's running in politics you're
gone yet that's exactly what he did he
said to his board I'm going to buy a
newspaper personally personally he
didn't say anything to the board listen
the point is he should have just this is
my own opinion you go to your board say
look I'm not I'm no longer going to be
myopically focused on Amazon one of the
most successful companies in the highest
peas in the world I'm going to get into
the newspaper business with a left-wing
newspaper that's going to take shoot
arrows at the president every day and I
wonder if he's going to get mad at me
like just think about that does that
make a laboratory in the president don't
think about bezos's views Bezos could do
whatever the hell he wants I don't think
well why because you've got a psycho
presence
television and run in politics I don't
think a CEO should own it what does this
have to do with every hour we're getting
calls from reporters on the Washington
Post uh we're asking ridiculous
questions and I will tell you
this is owned as a toy by Jeff Bezos who
controls Amazon he bought this paper for
practically nothing and he's using that
as a tool for political power against me
and against other people he's using the
Washington Post for power so that the
politicians in Washington don't tax
Amazon like they should be taxed trapezo
is made a gigantic commitment with his
climate fund and actually I am talking
to him well we will end up doing some
things in Partnership and at least we'll
see understand
what the other one is up to how might we
see you partnering with Jeff Bezos
uh well he's funded a lot of the key
climate organizations uh
you know we're talking about uh and he's
part of breakthrough energy Ventures uh
the idea of how you created demand side
for these green products even in the
early stage where their green premium
will be high uh that's an area where you
know we need something I've realized of
all the missing pieces uh and we talk
about that as as being catalytic in
nature we want to bring companies and
governments in on that but having a
strong base of philanthropic Capital to
get it started would would be fantastic
and yet you know Jeff Bezos obviously
has made that 10 billion dollar
commitment but these Amazon cardboard
boxes the blue and white envelopes I
hear even worse the trucks for delivery
I mean shouldn't a company as Innovative
as Amazon be able to figure that out
well they you can't put every societal
problem on Amazon uh they are part of
the physical economy delivering good so
of course their scope three emissions
are large you know they so there's
Amazon is a company that's committed to
Electric delivery vehicles and funding
uh Innovation and then there's Jeff is
an individual where that 10 billion uh
is even more than I've spent I've spent
a few billion and I'll spend a few
billion more uh in the years ahead so
you know in both cases I think you'll
see uh thoughtful ways of spending the
money but this requires you know all of
society to to get engaged
is it true that you were asked to go to
space by Jeff Bezos before William well
yeah provided I I pay you know
28 million bucks or something like that
I'm doing good Jimmy I'm doing good but
I ain't paying 28 bucks you know what we
could simulate The Experience sure of
going to space right now it's about a
12-minute flight is that about it yeah
we have the 12 minute flight okay this
is we can all do it in our seats right
here just leave you back like this lean
back like this and go
you do that that's it you do that for
four minutes all right do that for four
minutes and then you get up and you're
floating and just take off take off your
take off your seat belt whoa whoa
fabulous
and I
what get back in all right and another
four minutes
I don't need to spend 28 million bucks
to do that you're not going to do that I
can do that even if it was free you
wouldn't do that uh no I'd do it on
occasion just in order to experience the
joy Jeff Bezos was here last night and I
asked him what's the difference from
what you're doing and what Elon Musk is
doing and he said well I think we have
I think you use the word like-minded in
the general sense of it I think both
Jeff and I believe that is important for
the future to be a space praying
civilization
um and not the ultimately be out there
among the stars and I think that's the
that's the exciting inspiring future
that I think I think certainly people in
this room are whines Jeff Bezos
[Applause]
he's got cash but he writes a check the
bank bounce
yourself
Jeff Bezos is so rich he got divorced
and he's still the richest man in the
world
a marriage story and thought it was a
comedy
uh
Steve do you have anything you want to
add about Mr Bezos no I like getting my
packages on time
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see
what successful entrepreneurs think
about Elon Musk check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I saw you took a trip to the Tesla
Factory what were your thoughts after
meeting Elon Musk did he get to speak to
him much I wouldn't say much we we spoke
probably for 20 minutes in total not
purely privately because there's other
people around but that just barely